[Music]
um
next question number four in revelation
14 8 we see that babylon makes all
nations drink of the wine of the rat of
her fornication
what is that wine that makes the nations
drunk
wine in in in the bible not just
prophecy can refer to false truth not
it's not false truth false teaching or
the true teachings of god so it refers
to teachings doctrines when when jesus
said in the luke chapter 5 37 39 no man
peter new wine into all bottles christ
was referring to the fact that he came
to bring new light
to refresh the old teachings the jews
had misunderstood but they were not
changing and he said my new teachings
need to go into new people people whose
hearts are renewed but they were
refusing that and so wine represents
teachings doctrines truth
wine also represents error and so
babylon's wine is false teaching because
she made all nations drunk with the wine
of the wrath of a fornication the same
way
noah was made drunk by wine
in genesis chapter 9 he was made drunk
let me preach another sermon briefly
when noah was made drunk by wine noah
did not know what was happening to him
the person who abused him that person
knew what he was doing whatever the
abuse was
when lot had
sex with his two daughters
they made him drunk they were not drunk
you themselves they were it was willful
blatant flavor and deliberate
wine is used as a way of separating
people from their senses and so when lot
was drunk did not know what was
happening then his daughter slept with
him babylon has made churches drunk
there are people in churches who are
drunk doctrinally they are drunk with
respect to error and they have no clue
they simply believe if i make a lot of
noise if i shout loudly enough i'm
filled with the holy spirit of god the
only evidence of the the only reliable
evidence the only absolute evidence of
the presence of god is whether or not
people are following thus said the lord
not even a miracle is absolute proof
that god is present because the devil
can perform miracles and will perform
miracles according to 2nd thessalonians
chapter 2 from verse 9 and 10. and so
truth truth truth
is uh the the only thing that sustains
us and wine makes people drunk and the
people the drunk people are not even
aware they are drunk the leaders know
what they're doing most of them know
what they're doing but they keep the
people drunk so they can control the
people the truth of god brings you to
your senses let me say it again the
truth of god that's why jesus said the
truth shall make you free it brings you
to your senses david said open thou mine
eyes psalm 119 verse 130 the entrance of
thy word giveth light truth opens the
eyes and frees us from the bondage of
drunkenness and so babylon's crying is
that babylon made nations and rulers
drunk with the wine with false teaching
it's a very and the whole world
if you read uh revelation 12 verse lie
and the great dragon was cast out not
all serpent called the devil and satan
which deceiveth the whole world
deception is a twisting of the truth
that's why angels followed satan
revelation 12 9 because they were
deceived eve was deceived to deceive
you've got to meddle with the truth of
god and first john 5 19 and we know that
we are of god and the whole world lies
in wickedness virtually the entire world
is in a drunken state because the entire
world accepts error
in babylon's crime
is that it has preached error and most
people follow errol
well
praise god for that answer buster